Now let's go see all this in action with Dr.Zelicks and Callie the sea lion.
>> This is Carlie. Callie, can you wave hi? Good! Can you wave with the other
hand? Good, good. Here at Moss Landing Green Laboratories, we run a teaching
aquarium for students, can we salute? Good. From all over the world. The
beginning of the foundation of the relationship that I have with Carlie is
basic obedience. Water. Good. So I put her in the water when I ask. Hold. I can
ask her to wait there patiently for me. And the reason that she's willing to do
these things is because of the reinforcement history of
[INAUDIBLE]
conditioning that I have used to form these basic behaviors. The second basic
behavior that I have used all the time is one of the basic
[INAUDIBLE]
training techniques and it's called targeting good. This is a nose target. And
Carlie is trained to put her nose to my hand. Wherever I put my hand, Carlie's
nose is going to go. Good. And she stops targeting when she hears that sound
that I make which is called a bridge. A bridge is a stimulus that tells the
animal they've done something correctly, and reinforcement is coming. There's a
type of secondary reinforcer, a conditioned reinforcer which helps the animal
understand the reinforcement is on its way, without having to deliver the
reinforcement at that very second. Carllie is receiving a variety of different
types of reinforcers. That right there is an ice cube, which she's been
conditioned to like. And we've conditioned her to like it by association with
other things that she already likes. Including, the fish. And then there's also
her relationship with me. This is tactile reinforcement that she has to be
trained to enjoy. Yes! Don't stop! Yes! Don't stop! One of the things that
comes from being associated with reinforcement for a long period of time is the
relationship. Through classical conditioning by associating myself with all
good experiences for her, I have a strong value to her, I have more value than
the food has. And we're demonstrating that right now because the food is over
there and she and I are right here together. That's what can be formed with a
long history of partnership. Yes? Good! Alright